a very good morning good to have you
with us an independent report on the
chaotic scenes that last year's
Champions League final between Liverpool
and Real Madrid says it was European
football's governing body UEFA and the
French authorities who were responsible
for what it says almost turned into a
mass fatality catastrophe
thousands of Liverpool fans were tear
gassed which caused crushing outside of
the stud to France the head of the match
at the time the behavior of those
supporters was under question but the
document commissioned by UEFA itself and
seen first by Sky News has found that
the French authorities tried to deflect
responsibility onto English fans
following false claims that many of them
had fake tickets our Sports
correspondent Rob Harris has the story
it was the biggest night of the European
football season that almost led to a
disaster with Liverpool fans forced to
endure crushing and congestion
they were initially falsely blamed for
the 2022 Champions League final chaos
but in a review first revealed by Sky
News safety failings and misleading
statements by authorities are now clear
UEFA who commissioned the report were
found to Bear primary responsibility for
the failure as the ultimate event
organizers
but the police and French Football
Federation are also found culpable for
not protecting the public sufficiently
it's here where the failing's trying to
control the crowds were most apparent a
bottleneck formed of Liverpool fans and
what the review found is there should
have been a plan B to deal with
situations as they developed but there
were no contingencies to ensure that
police and stewards could be redeployed
to deal with issues as they developed
it's been revealed there was no venue
risk assessment
these were the main access points for
Liverpool fans but the turnstiles were
closed for parts of the night as police
struggled to deal with locals trying to
climb over the fences to access the
stadium tear gas and pepper spray was
used to proactively the review finds and
that police were wrong to deploy tigers
and pepper spray in this scenario it led
to blameless Liverpool fans suffering it
was absolute mess no organization
um totally people worried about the skin
and when the announcer will come over on
the screen we were quite lucky we got in
before it got really bad and we had
phone calls from home you know because
he'd seen on the Telly just there
blaming us from the start and the first
thing you think of is what's happened in
the past the review uncovered a policing
operation wrongly based on Liverpool
fans being a threat
UEFA was found to have marginalized its
Safety and Security unit there was a
lack of contingencies and overall
communication between UEFA and French
officials was poor I don't believe at
all authorities have taken this
seriously they thought that they could
get away with scapegoat dogs in
Liverpool fans because it's worked in
the past and it's only because of the
vigilance and the stoicism of funds that
once again the truth has come out the
Liverpool fans who were smeared in Paris
have been exonerated and UEFA have
apologized
but how close fans came to losing their
lives and the attempts to deflect blame
will be hard to forget for those
subjected to Danger
and Rob joins me now live from Paris uh
good morning to Rob certainly uh this
report seems to lay the blame squarely
at UEFA and French authorities so
understandably a lot of Anger from
Liverpool fans over the false accusation
initially
yeah a lot of Anger from those Liverpool
fans who endured that night in Paris
here last May at the emergency side
diabet last night they were telling us
of how they feel Vindicated to see this
account now put out there to show
actually it was the French Authority's
annue for responsible for a match that
did start 37 minutes late in the end
such was the disarray unfolding in the
stadium behind me in the outer
perimeters and certainly from the French
authorities we haven't actually heard
anything following the publication of
this report we were trying to make
contact with them yesterday and the
hours before we broke the news of the
key findings of this investigation there
was a partial apology last year from the
French interior Minister but certainly
there are many questions this report
raises about their conduct the fact they
ordered they asked UEFA on the night to
remove references from their statement
to locals causing trouble trying to
climb into the stadium there are attacks
on fans on the night and the lack of
connectivity between UEFA and the French
police and government is certainly
something highlighted in this report as
a problem and it will be a concern going
forward we are just months away from the
Rugby Union World Cup starting here in
September there's also the Olympics here
in 2024 the stat de France one of the
venues for that so France is at the
center of World Sports over the next
year very different events of course
from a Champions League final and
actually that's something also signified
in the report as well the fact the
outdated plans that were being used by
UEFA basing their model on a different
type of game and still there will be
questions today about those UEFA
officials who are presiding over the
night in their events division one
official in particular criticized for
the truthfulness of the evidence he gave
to the French Senate and how he seemed
to claim to have a lack of knowledge of
past instances at this stage in past
crowd challenges Cross organization no
challenges and yet he claimed not to
know about them despite seemingly
actually being aware of them so what is
clear from this report is a far Graver
situation could have unfolded last year
at the stad de France there could well
have been death the report makes clear
and certainly what will be sought now
are assurances from the French
authorities over how this could be
prevented in future and from UEFA how
they all ensure there are better checks
on stages they're using for the biggest
games of the season
yeah certainly all very important points
you mentioned there Rob with the World
Cup just a few months away good to see
you thanks very much indeed
now just a breaking news to bring you
the ons has just released lots of new
data including revealing just how many
working days have been lost due to
strike action in recent months and our
business correspondent gurpreet narwin
is here now with all the details hi girl
free so numbers just in how are they
looking and what do they tell us about
the state of the economy yeah there's a
lot in this report and I'm going to get
to the strike data in a second because
it is really important but I'm going to
start from the beginning because there's
a lot in here and the main message is
that the jobs Market is starting to
weaken redundancies are up vacancies are
falling the unemployment rate still
stable at 3.7 but we expect that those
redundancies and vacancies figures will
start filtering into the unemployment
rate in many ways this tells us what we
already know our economy is pretty weak
we're the only G7 economy that hasn't
recovered to its pre-pandemic size and
we're heading for a recession now that
being said 3.7 unemployment it's still
pretty low by historic standard our
labor market is actually still pretty
tight we've got millions of people who
are inactive that means they're not even
looking for work they may have retired
early they may be too sick to work and a
smaller labor force increases
competition for jobs which puts pressure
on wages and policy makers are keeping a
really close eye on this because when
wages go up that could fuel inflation
and at the moment in the private sector
wages are Rising by 7.3 percent still
lower than inflation which means living
standards are falling but uncomfortably
high for the bank of England and all of
this is leading to An Almighty Fallout
as we can see in the form of strikes all
over the country and data route today
shows that there were 843
000 days lost to strike action that's
working days lost to strike action in
December alone that's the highest since
November 2011 and if we take a broader
View and and have a look at the data
since June 2.4 million days we lost to
strike action that's the highest annual
figure since 1989 so despite policy
makers warnings about higher wages which
could fuel inflation it's quite clear
that people aren't willing to see their
living standards decline yeah and
certainly not that surprising those uh
strike figures there given what we saw
in December thanks so much
also this morning the United States has
accused Beijing of running a high
altitude balloon program even though it
says there is no indication yet that the
three most recent objects it shot down
were the same type of balloon used by
Beijing and brought down 10 days ago but
tension between the two countries has
increased including a news conference
last night at the White House
we were able to determine that China has
a high altitude balloon program for
intelligence collection that's connected
to the people's Liberation Army
it was operating during the previous
administration but they did not detect
it we detected it we tracked it
and we have been carefully studying it
to learn as much as we can
be speaking at a press conference last
night well let's bring in Asia
correspondent Helen Ann Smith who's
standing by in Beijing for us uh hello
to you Helen and certainly it seems
tensions between the US and China are
increasing and there's a very real
concern that things could escalate
yeah that's right and in that press
conference there that you heard from
actually the accusations being leveled
by the Americans to China are not
necessarily new ones that accusation of
this high altitude balloon program or a
fleet of balloons as it was called last
week was made on Friday but the
Americans clearly Keen to either keep
the public informed or indeed perhaps
keep up pressure on the Chinese and
there's no doubt at all that here in
Beijing authorities are really pretty
angry about it they the Chinese sticking
absolutely resolutely to the line that
the first balloon that was shot down by
the Americans uh just over a week ago
now that's the only one that the Chinese
have claimed is theirs but say as a
civilian craft absolutely resolutely
sticking to that line that it was a
civilian craft and that the American
response to that was an overreaction but
the Americans also gave us some slightly
new information yesterday we found out
that from that debris that's been
collected from that first balloon then
amongst that was what they described as
a key electronics and key sensors
presumably used for intelligence
gathering again the Americans did say
last week that they do have strong
evidence now they believe to say that
that balloon was a spy balloon but but
just reiterating at that point there the
mystery as you say continues over those
three unidentified craft that were shot
down over America and Canada over the
weekend actually the Americans knew all
the Canadians at the moment can say
exactly what they are or where they've
come from and there's problems Gathering
some of those bits but clearly a lot of
tension over this and the Chinese for
their part as I said not confirming or
denying that any of those unidentified
craft are theirs in fact even giving an
indication that they're preparing to
shoot down an object over its airspace
so uh really a messy situation hard to
believe really that just over a week and
a half and ago the U.S Secretary of
State was due to visit Beijing it feels
a long way from that now
yeah it certainly does Helen good to see
you thanks very much indeed and we will
have more on that story throughout the
program here on Sky news this morning
to other news now and Buckingham Palace
says Camilla the queen consort has
tested positive for covid 75 year old
has canceled her public engagements for
a week after a positive test result and
we can bring in Skies Becky Cottrell for
more on this who's outside Buckingham
Palace this morning morning to you Becky
certainly the queen consort at 75 years
old is in one of the higher risk
categories so a concern still for
Camilla
a concern but the palace says she's in
good spirits that she's resting and is
disappointed she's had to cancel events
this week and they've apologized to
those who were due to attend the first
we'd heard of this was yesterday when
the palace said they were postponing
Camilla's events and that she had a
seasonal illness it seems that a cover
test was done they got a positive result
and it was later but we had the
announcement that she had covered 19. I
think the wording in the statement from
the palace symptoms of a cold would
suggest that she isn't seriously ill
it's not the first time that Camilla has
had covid she called it at a similar
time last year she has to do the same
thing cancel her public engagements
while she took time to recover but we do
understand that she and the king have
had all of their Jabs including the
booster and we know how much
vaccinations have helped with this virus
they've allowed us to kind of carry on
with our lives previously as you
mentioned there would have been a lot of
concern particularly about older people
catching this virus Camilla is 75 it
doesn't mean to say people can't still
get seriously ill with covert but
hopefully with her Jabs with some rest
the queen consult will have a smooth
recovery her catching covert is also a
reminder not that many of us needed it
many of us do know people still getting
covered but it is a reminder that this
virus is still very much around and
something that we are having to deal
with but we do understand that no other
member of the royal household at the
moment has caught coven and the king is
set to continue with his input with his
public engagements later this week
although without the queen consort okay
Becky for now thanks very much
still to come on the show this morning
in a few minutes we'll get some reaction
to the Champions League Report with a
Liverpool fan who was at the match that
day sports journalist Dan Austin
shortly after we'll hear about the
challenges being faced by the children
caught up in last week's earthquakes
with unicef's Carmen monclue
and then just after eight I'll be joined
by Labor's Shadow exchecker secretary to
the treasury of Bina upon asari
[Music]
now it's being reported this morning
that Syria's president Assad will open
more Crossing points into his country to
allow more Aid to be sent to the
survivors of the two earthquakes which
destroyed parts of turkey and Syria the
death toll has now reached more than 35
000 and many of the people who did
survive are now struggling to live well
we can speak now to Skies called Delia
Lynch who's in the city of Adana in the
south of the country morning to Cordelia
so it seems more Aid will be arriving
for Syria but certainly it seems more
helpers needed desperately everywhere
that's right Sally it's a desperate
situation here in turkey and even more
so in Syria the UN has welcomed the
agreement from Assad that you will allow
for two more Crossing points to get in
that vital Aid that follows a meeting
between the U.N humanitarian Chief
Richard Griffiths who is meeting with
Assad and what he described as a
positive and constructive meeting the
white helmets though a key rescue group
operating in the rebel held Northwest
have said that that gives Assad free
political gain it is of course a deeply
free but febrile situation there but
Richard Griffith said that the aid must
get through throughout Syria in those
areas that need it now I'm in Adana this
is an area that's normally a market
Sally it now has 1500 people that have
been disc placed because of the
earthquake here they are still finding
buildings that are structurally unsafe
and we have witnessed the devastation
the desperation that continues here
yesterday we were in antakia in the
South where we saw the last efforts
being made efforts trained on this one
particular building where they were able
miraculously to rescue a mother and
father they were hoping that their 26
year old son could make it through we
were there for eight hours as they were
using thermal equipment sniffer dogs as
they are in in pockets of turkey here
despite the fact it is more than a week
since the earthquake hit unfortunately
here in that instance did not make it
through and I think hope now is
desperately fading one of the things
I've been very conscious of is the mix
here you were seeing some areas where
they've got a lot of heavy equipment and
others that feel bereft of help quite
frankly and at the core here is a
conversation around the structural
safety of the buildings we're in
iskendra and that was one area that was
obliterated it's a blitz-like image in
that town I spoke to one man who just
made it out of his building the one next
to it completely obliterated and you're
hearing a lot of discussion of people
saying that these were profiteering
contractors who were you know trying to
make money at the expense of safety I
think we'll hear more about that in the
days to come yeah certainly something
we've heard a lot of is that earthquakes
don't kill people buildings do we
appreciate your update Cordelia thank
you
let's have a look at some of today's
other headlines now and three people
have been killed after a shooting at
Michigan State University with the
gunman reported to have died from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound police say
five people have also been taken to
hospitals some in a life-threatening
condition
thousands of students will face
disruption as universities staff walk
out later more than 70 000 staff from
the University and college Union are set
to strike in a dispute overpay pensions
and conditions it's the first of three
consecutive days of action across 150
universities in the UK
Amazon workers have announced further
strikes at one of the company's
warehouses in a dispute overpay the GMB
union says more than 350 staff at the
Fulfillment center in Coventry will walk
out on dates throughout February and
March last month they became the first
Amazon workers in the UK to strike
now New Zealand has declared a national
state of emergency as the country
continues to be battered by Cyclone
Gabrielle well Sky's Nicole Johnston is
following the story from Sydney for us
hello to you Nicole now New Zealand does
not call these states of emergency very
often what's the situation
well the situation does appear to be
deteriorating some 225
000 people across the north island of
New Zealand are now without power only a
few hours ago that number was around 40
000. so officials are certainly
concerned as you said they don't
normally declare these states of
Emergency the last time was during the
covert pandemic and the Christ Church
earthquake so they're really worried
about Rising flood waters damaged
infrastructure roads Bridges footage is
coming out of people waiting on their
rooftops to be rescued the military's
been called in 200 Personnel are trying
to help with it there is expected to be
a weakening of this ex-tropical Cyclone
on Wednesday as it starts to move from
the North Island to the South Island but
clearly New Zealand has a massive
cleanup operation ahead of it and this
is the second Mass flooding event
they've had in the last two weeks
an extraordinary period Nicole thanks so
much
now NATO's Chief has warned that
Russia's new offensive in Ukraine has
already begun as NATO defense ministers
meet in Brussels or Europe correspondent
Adam Parsons is outside NATO
headquarters in Brussels for us this
morning uh hello to you Adam what can we
expect today do you think uh NATO
defense ministers will be under pressure
to offer more to Ukraine given that this
latest offensive seems to have already
started
yeah I think they will be I think there
is going to be pressure the question is
what is that support going to look like
the in stoltenberg has already said that
he recognizes that there is growing
pressure to supply fighter jets to
Ukraine I think that that everyone here
all the defense ministers meeting here
will probably be reluctant to take that
big step because frankly if supplying
fighter jets a looks like an escalation
B logistically it's very complicated and
C there are questions about just how
helpful that is bearing in mind how long
it takes to train people to fly these
Jets because another point that Jen
stoltenberg is making is that Ukraine is
getting through a vast amount of
Munitions and I think one of the points
he will say to these ministers is we
need to step up industrial production if
Ukraine is going to get through
thousands of bits of Munitions so
quickly on a daily basis we need to be
able to provide those I think he will
say that they this will get less
headlines than sending fighter jets but
actually on the ground is more important
because he will look towards Russia he
says that the latest Russian offensive
has already started we're looking at
bahamuta and it's quite clear that that
uh that offensive is being focused on
that area and he will brief ministers
that Russia is sending thousands and
thousands and thousands of Truth and
he's prepared to accept high levels of
casualties that more Munitions more
armaments more support needs to go to
Ukraine on the ground as well as this
consideration of jets I'm sure they will
also find time to talk about Chinese
balloons that are floating over North
America as well I'm sure it is a surreal
times Adam thanks so much
let's get more on our top story now and
that's that Liverpool fans have been
cleared after a review commissioned by
UEFA found that both they and the French
authorities are to blame for the chaotic
scenes that last year's Champions League
final in Paris
well I'm joined now by the sports
journalist Dan Austin who is at the
match as a Liverpool fan good to see you
Dan thanks for joining us uh tell us
what you remember about that day and
what happened to you
uh well it was it was horrendous to be
honest
um I attended the fan was stuck in
really dangerous crushing outside the
stadium for uh almost three hours before
what was the supposed kickoff time uh
women children disabled people were were
tear gas hit with riot shields and
people suffering really terrible anxiety
attacks it was it was not the kind of
thing that anybody should ever be
subjected to in a major sport or
entertainment event
now the French police were very
heavy-handed that day tell us what it
was like
um well yes they they treated Liverpool
supporters the way they treat their own
citizens on a day-to-day basis really
I.E
um storming into uh masses of people
with batons at the ready tear gas riot
shields in order to try and control
people that they view inherently as
animals as opposed to human beings they
had a flawed understanding of football
in this country they had a flawed
understanding of things like the
Hillsborough disaster and went to that
match with the idea that these were
people who were automatically Hooligans
who were there to cause trouble and
there to be violent was absolutely not
the case
um Liverpool and I'm pretty much all of
the the top English clubs that play in
Europe at this stage do not have
um modern histories of organism or
anything like that
um this was a deeply forward policing
strategy which is quite rightly in this
report
um being called up for what it was which
was the the a significant part of the
root cause of all of the Carnage that
occurred
now this report does completely
exonerate Liverpool fans uh that must be
somewhat of a relief after the initial
response in France
will it vindicate everybody who has put
the effort in over the past nine months
it is at this stage in order to make
sure that the truth is known and the
authorities the you know various French
government ministers you wait for itself
all conducted a very targeted campaign
from even before the match kicked off to
try and blame supporters you know they
had the message on the big screen UAE
for saying that the late arrival of fans
um was the course of the delay to
kickoff that was absolutely not the case
it was objectively untrue uh the
reporters found that
and what it also means is that this
isn't just about this one event and and
Liverpool supporters the the reason that
everybody wants to speak up as much as
they've done and they've done so really
successfully to be proud of themselves
because they've changed the narrative is
so that it doesn't happen again in the
future either uh UEFA Champions League
finals or they're very sort of their
major events saying whether that be all
those games or Europa League finals
whatever that's what's important now
um the report found that it was
remarkable that nobody lost their life
at UEFA showpiece event that's that's
staggering and disgraceful
um and if they don't Implement series
changes and understand what they did
wrong and how then unfortunately nobody
that attends their Adventures going to
be safe in their care that's what now
has to be different because next time it
could be anybody else any any English
team any European team playing in a
major event at the moment because
uefaith was not actually take its
responsibility to Safety and Security
seriously it does not actually oversee
its own policies or take them seriously
that means that that everybody who
attends one of their events is currently
unsafe and that is completely utterly
unacceptable
now uh Hillsborough of course it was a
long time ago uh 34 years ago nearly now
um but it's still a very raw memory uh
for the people of Liverpool how much was
this experience in Paris last year how
much did that add to the trauma for for
Liverpool fans uh in terms of the legacy
of Hillsborough and and also how much
did it help that you already had
experience and have talked about it in
to such to such an extent dealing with a
situation like that
well as I said deeply for deeply Falls
understanding of what happened to
Hillsborough is partly the reason it
occurs at all UEFA and the French police
seem to have this idea that something
from 33 years ago where supporters were
the victims of State negligence
essentially
um was a valid way to to kind of
strategize policing for their events
that was that was disgraceful and
downright offensive really in the first
place but
the fact that Liverpool supporters have
been through that and and over three
decades and first of all meant that that
nobody died people knew what to do
people knew how to look after one
another people knew how to behave even
people like me who are not alive at the
time of Hillsborough
you you grow up in a post Hillsborough
Wales where your whales view is is
inherently shaped by it the kinds of
social grief that you inherit is is
always there so people have
a kind of lanes distrust of authority
um people are willing to stand up for
one another that's just kind of built in
and that meant that people knew what to
do during and afterwards they knew to
document everything that was happening
they knew to gather loads of Audio
Visual Evidence and post it online and
they knew how to conduct a
Communications campaign that was
significantly better than that of the
authorities what's actually happened in
the past few months is Liverpool fans
have had this report come through one
from Phil strayton one of the most
respected academics in the country and
Beyond and also one from the French
Senate all of which completely generate
the fans and it's because the way that
people communicated on the night and
since then
it was significantly better than the way
that the authorities did they tried to
cover this up and were simply not
competent enough to do so the people
that that support Liverpool that went to
that match on the night and the
campaigns ever since have proven
themselves more competent more
intelligent
more talented downright than those
people who who tried to blame them and
who are in worryingly powerful positions
in both governing European football and
also wider French society
yeah certainly uh hopefully this report
will bring some comfort to them Dan I
would really appreciate your Insight
today Dan Austin thanks so much for
joining us thanks thank you
let's have a look at the weather now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
it'll stay dry and settled for most
today but it will turn wetter and
windier tomorrow I'm afraid Britain will
be mostly sunny but Frosty for the first
part of this morning with some dense fog
in places mainly the southeast the Far
West Island and Northern Ireland will be
milder but largely overcast
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well it's Valentine's Day so we asked
for some people to find the top chat up
lines which could make all the
difference and we went to the world's
favorite artificial intelligence chat
bots so could his metal hearts have the
chance of winning your love this
Valentine's Day we even got a human
judge and dating expert to see what she
thought of its matchmaking potential
we'll hear some of chat gpt's top chat
up lines do bear with me uh do you have
a map I keep getting lost in your eyes
oh my goodness I'm actually gonna have
to read these out uh dating coach Hayley
Quinn says physical Compliments are
dodgy territories she suggests
complimenting them on an aspect of their
personality probably quite good advice
another Gambit if you were a vegetable
you'd be a cucumber
it goes on Haley doesn't mind this one
apparently in the age of dating apps
funny first messages can go a long way
that's true right people like a bit of a
laugh the chatbot tries compliments too
your smile is so warm and inviting
uh and Haley say this is presumptive to
the point
of creepy
well I'm afraid um we'll have more on
that throughout the show so apologies if
you found any of that very creepy but
Happy Valentine's Day and coming up
we'll be speaking more about the
situation in turkey and Syria to UNICEF
Child Protection specialist common clue
about the challenges faced by children
caught up in last week's earthquakes do
stay with us for that
foreign
welcome back to Sky News breakfast and
let's get more reaction now to the ons
figures out this morning which show that
the number of days lost to strike action
in 2022 was the highest since 1989 well
Ali's here uh with more on this and Ali
we've just had some reaction to these
ons figures from the chancellor yes
exactly reaction just in so this is
Jeremy Hunt the chancellor he says in
tough times unemployment remaining close
to record lows is an encouraging sign of
resilience in our labor market the best
thing we can do is make sure people's
wages go further is to stick to the plan
we have to have inflation this year so
again I think sort of what we would
expect from the chancellor talking about
the need to get down inflation first
that isn't going to stop people that say
hold on there's there's pretty
extraordinary that we're talking about
so many strike days more than any time
since the 80s obviously that's having an
impact on the work Falls and there are
plenty including the British Chamber of
Commerce who say that the transfer needs
to do something in the budget a month
tomorrow to help with labor workforce
shortages that is one of the big keys to
tackling
um some of the problems he's facing but
a response just in to those figures okay
thanks for that uh Ali and certainly
Jeremy Hunt may say he wants to get
costs down for people but one cost that
looks set to rise for almost everyone is
council tax yeah that's right so um
these this these are figures that
effectively suggest that and we know
this is something that Jeremy Hunt made
possible in the Autumn statement
councils can now raise council tax by
five percent it's easier to do without a
local vote that was something that was
made possible in the Autumn statement
and we're seeing councils doing that
according to this new research from
County council's Network three quarters
of councils plan a five percent tax rise
that is about 99 pounds a year if you're
living in a band empty home so that's a
home costing between 68 and 88 000
pounds we're setting three councils
Croydon thurrock and
um Slough also have special dispensation
to go even further with tax Rises
obviously we know that councils say that
they've been struggling that's why they
need to raise council tax because of
inflation because more people are coming
to them asking for support but obviously
this is knocking that on to people
struggling to pay their bills the
government have released a statement
they talk about the 60 billion pounds
funding settlement and nine percent
increase on the year before they say
councils need to ease pressure on people
but obviously this is not good for
people paying their bills help for
energy bills is also going to go down a
bit at the end of March as well and
again another pressure on the chancellor
head of the budget yeah certainly
pressure on the chancellor and a lot of
pressure on so many households Ali
thanks so much
let's return to the situation in Turkey
in Syria now the death pole the death
toll excuse me has surpassed 35
000 people and millions who have
survived have been left homeless
sleeping in cars and Tents in freezing
conditions well many of those affected
our children and for more on this I'm
joined Now by Child Protection
specialist with UNICEF Carmen monclue uh
very good morning to you thank you for
joining us now I understand you've been
working on unicef's response in
Northwest Syria what are the main issues
facing children there
yes good morning uh to all of you
um well as you have seen the impact of
the queer the earthquake had been
disproportionately affected children
um we do have now a situation where
we're moving towards recovery slowly
slowly after the rescue efforts
um we have about approximately what we
think is an estimate for now is 1.8
million children in need of a
humanitarian assistance and this is
quite an immediate figure among them we
find a lot of unaccompanied and
separated children
um
as it is very normal after a natural
disaster of this Dimension so all
efforts are being made for uh doing the
family tracing and reunification on one
hand while at the same time keeping
these children safe and increasing our
safe cars particularly now it's very
important these children are are planted
the protection and the care that they
need we do have a family tracing and
rectification mechanism the teams are
working around the clock for as much as
it's humanly possible at the moment
we are also providing psychosocial
support and mental health to to the
children and their parents and
caregivers and slowly slowly our teams
are are coming
um active in we might recognize such a
lot of the uh people affected affected
population have been the agency
themselves also on the ground the
agencies who are actually delivering
those services so at the time we we have
so many needs and and we see how
exponentially
it it has impacted children it's when we
have less muscle than before we already
departed from a very low Baseline as you
know we had an armed conflict ongoing in
the in the region and therefore there
was already an emergency uh response so
now all efforts are being made to
reactivate it to renew um to make all
the mobile teams that we had active and
multiplicate those when when it's
possible particularly in the most
affected areas
our children in danger in Syria
following this earthquake
indeed they are in danger they are in
danger they face multiple risks
um and all efforts are being made to
mitigate those and prevent those we can
talk about physical danger of course I
mean we're talking about a high level of
Destruction
um this hasn't hasn't been yet
um
[Music]
control
um it's still under the recovery
reconstruction phase and it will be so
for for quite some time
um we're also talking about multiple uh
effects on their psychosocial on their
um development
um on their physical and emotional
safety and this is something that we're
working towards that we already had
quite a specialized teams on the ground
before this was a very solid operation
with all the limitations that we had but
it is essential now that we continue and
Revitalize those structures that we had
to the uh speak to the highest speed
possible
um commonly just very briefly Before I
Let You Go it must be absolutely
heartbreaking to see these children
going through so much especially after
12 years of War uh what is happening to
Children who've been orphaned or
separated from their parents
well as I said initially we do have a
um Family tracing and reunification
mechanism which is manned actually it's
it's being managed from this house from
the UNICEF house here in cross border in
gaziente and all children that are found
separated or indications that are
separated must be registered this is
essential this is the very initial step
very important that every child is
registered in those circumstances an
initial assessment is made it's an
individual assessment every child is
different and opportunities and
challenges may vary from one child to
the other and therefore at response to
that child will be tailored to that the
best interest of the child are an
absolute priority in each of those cases
there won't be a solution that suits
them all that's rather a very intense
labor type of work that the teams are
doing trying to identify what's the best
solution for every individual child many
of those children may appear initially
separated but then it's found out they
are not so it's all this kind of work
which is requires a lot of accuracy a
lot of rigor is what is required at the
moment in the common one clue we're
going to have to leave it there common
one clue from UNICEF we appreciate you
taking time uh while you're doing so
much important work thank you very much
indeed for joining us thank you thank
you very much and have a good morning
you too thank you
now as we've been reporting the United
States has accused Beijing of running a
high altitude balloon program and to
talk more about this with me is former
British Army intelligence and security
officer Philip Ingram a very good
morning to you Philip good to see you
it's been an extraordinary uh set of
events that's taken place in the last
couple of weeks over U.S and Canadian
airspace How concerned do we need to be
about Chinese surveillance
well surveillance status surveillance is
nothing new you're the second oldest
professional is going on on a daily
basis this is just another technique
that the Americans have retuned their
sensors to be able to identify and find
and we've only had one balloon that's
been identified as a Chinese spy balloon
the others are all anomalies and objects
that the Americans haven't defined what
they are yet
now the White House said that um you
know China's been using these balloons
across several continents multiple
countries they've been seeing this sort
of activity for years so why are we only
hearing so much detail about them now
well I think the seeing for years I
think they're looking back at some of
the historical records the the issue
that there's been is from a technical
perspective of most of the civil as
Radars looking for threats are looking
for things that are moving fast that
they're metal objects that they've got
set parameters and those are what The
Radars and the other sensors are looking
for the balloons are operating where
they're moving very slowly they're
changing Heights that some of them are
operating very high indeed they have a
very very small radar signature and all
the filters that there were in the
surveillance systems were filtering
these out they didn't see them as a
threat so the Americans and others
around the world weren't seeing them now
that they've looked at the Chinese spine
and put these parameters back into their
filters and they've suddenly gone oh my
goodness we can see lots and they've
gone back historically and seen that
there has been a bit of a program of
these going across continental US
they're very weather dependent and
they're they're not as easy to control
as people would um think
now of course as you say Philip at the
U.S and China have been spying on each
other uh for a very long time this is
nothing new and the U.S tends to use
surveillance aircraft which of course do
fly fairly close to China uh could we be
at risk of escalation here if a
surveillance aircraft were to be shot
out of the sky by China is that
something that that could happen
well the Chinese have already escorted
um U.S surveillance aircraft that they
have said have gone into Chinese
airspace and forced them to land um and
there have been a number of incidents
over the years so it escalates
diplomatically the issue that there is
with balloons is that they are physical
devices flying in another country's
airspace and international law requires
you to fire to file a flight plan a
flight plan and to um say where they are
for for safety reasons and this is what
didn't happen here and that's why this
has sort of blown up into a little bit
of a diplomatic spat it's a it's a speed
bump it's no more than that it's because
international law hasn't been followed
and there's a theoretical threat to
um commercial airlines or or military
aircraft because a sovereign bit of
airspace has been invaded by another
country
um and that that's what's causing this
and it's you know the Americans relying
I think slightly embarrassed that
they've realized it's been going on for
a while
yeah it's only extraordinary but serious
stuff Philip Ingram thanks so much for
your analysis thank you thank you
now coming up I will be joined by the
director general of the British Chambers
of Commerce to discuss the latest
employment figures do stay with us for
that that's coming up
[Music]
welcome back now new figures out this
morning from the office for National
statistics show that although the
unemployment rate remains pretty much
the same slightly more people are now in
work with part-time staff driving up the
numbers let's get more on this with the
director general of the British Chambers
of Commerce Siobhan Haviland good to see
you should that have said slightly more
people are out of work than than
previous unemployment figures and and
indeed what do these figures tell you
about the health of the UK economy
generally this morning yeah so so the
numbers have improved slightly but we
still have 1.1 million open roles in
this country which means that businesses
are still really struggling to find
people and that is impacting the growth
of their businesses so our businesses
are telling us they still can't find
enough people they can't fulfill their
order books they can't keep their hotel
running at capacity and it's a real
Challenge and would you say that is that
is the major issue that the UK economy
is facing right now is this shortfall in
in the Workforce that people just
haven't returned to work after the
pandemic it's absolutely the number one
thing that our businesses are telling us
they're struggling with their energy
bills too but finding people is is the
number one thing and that is not just
people not returning after the pandemic
uh it is parents struggling with child
care we want to see simpler more
affordable child care it is getting
older people back into work but it's
also all around just shortages of people
so we are saying to the government we'd
like them to review their shortage
occupation list so we can bring people
into the economy in certain sectors at
the right time and what would make a
difference what would what would help
with this Workforce shortfall that we're
seeing in the country so I would say a
couple of things uh spring budget is
coming up so we'd like to see the chance
to do something on child care and that
might be affordability of child care but
also Supply it's important to retrain
older people to get them back into work
and businesses need to have flexible
shifts for that but it's also a question
of looking at how we can bring more
labor into the market and just very
briefly how much have strikes impacted
and exacerbated our economic pain
it's another challenge for business
business like Clarity and certainty so
they can invest this just adds more
stress into the system so it's really
important for everyone to get around the
table and fix the problems now the IMF
recently forecast that we would be the
only leading economy to slide into
recession this year do you agree with
that do you see do you see that
happening it's going to be a challenging
year it is and we're still going to see
labor shortages and challenges around
energy bills but I have the pleasure of
traveling the country and meeting
businesses all over our regions and
Nations and they are resilient and they
are can do and they will find Solutions
but it is going to be a tough year
tougher here than elsewhere
it's going to be tougher yes but it's
tough for everyone okay she won't have a
land it's been really good to see you
and talk to you about this thanks so
much for joining us
now stay with us uh here on Sky
breakfast Skinny's breakfast we have
more on the independent report on the
trouble at last year's Champions League
final in Paris will be speaking to a
Liverpool fan who was at the start de
France that day caught up in the chaos
he'd also been at Hillsborough as well
and we'll have his story coming up in
the next hour stay with us
foreign